hier ist das obsidian er okay ich hab
alles was er die level aber die level
ruhig mit zurück dabei eiskalt
ich hol dir die comcom ja ich bespreche
ich mit dem 1 0 hatte ich schon selber
macht ihr indem ihr auf man sieht er als
wenn ich jungen oder so das war ja
wirklich gerade ich war dumm ist oder so
sei es eine wirklich also ist sich das
kommt aus richtung wäre aber jetzt
wirklich an einem fehler im spiel mit
dem was kann auch jeder nachvollziehen
das sonderangebot ist als er vom kopf
wiederum holt keine kommentare schreiben
gericht natürlich richtig drauf schreibt
mal okay wenn ihr das jetzt sieht
schreibt alle ok um gespielt meint dass
alle bei mir unterschreiben soll nicht
nur holz und dann sagt ich schreibt alle
bei mir darunter
ich bin ganz ganz toll und wir
respektieren dass du dich nicht mehr
zeigen willst da schreibt jetzt wird
lange darunter leiden dagegen aktion
respekt ist aber gar nicht vorhanden wir
sagen einfach hallo immer konkreter
du bist ein kleiner schock steht ihr
seid schreiben
wenn du was besseres bis dann bitte geh
doch holdorf wie viele lassen eigene
levels 31 ich war schon wieder fast im
boden
ihr müsst ihr portal vielleicht einen
einen noch über ihr wohnsitzen ja ich
mache ich jetzt auch so dass wir immer
das was bin so froh dass ich so eine
portugal gefunden haben das ist echt
lustig ich hab es besser also warte das
mache ich in der höhle enorm wobei ich
danke euch bei einer höhle auch schon
wieder am boden bist du nie passierte
bodenwanne noch nie ja aber ich weiß
noch bei dir der anfang ich bin im boden
gefunden
das müsse noch mal üben das ist übrigens
auch richtig geil dass ihr alle vize des
best aufs macht ich finde das richtig
geil da gibt es so viele schon richtig
hammer hat schon zehn zwölf videos oder
so westhoff es richtig hammer
was wir hier für eine community haben du
reste komme ich auf youtube darf schon
mal anders schon mal nicht schlecht oder
ja ich find's cool das kommt er doch
noch wird noch schöner
ich finds auch ganz geil wenn wir hier
das hat mich ein ich weiß zwar dass
extra mit den tiefs hier jetzt habe ich
nur als blöcke gemacht habe ich das
schnell drauf gehen könnte
was meinst du liebst dass wir hier
eventuell so ein bisschen lief an der
decke machen und zwar so ein paar
baumstämme runterfallen lassen mit so
ein bisschen liebst dran das ist ein
bisschen verwurzelt aussieht das habe
ich aus dem kreise straile dass wir
einfach so mit mit mit blöcken mit
holzblöcken von da oben so ein bisschen
runter gehen dann so liest ankommen dass
ich mich dabei cool aus mit dem gestern
sieht und es stimmt ja könnten wir so
sagt designer so ausmachen und das
verschiedene räume ein wenig lasst uns
wirklich sollen rein machen sollen du
machst so komische sachen oder einfach
gut macht du die soll nicht nach die
komischen sachen so hast du liest dann
gibt er dir am besten haben ganz viele
guck mal hier die kiste ich habe das mit
den design und du machst du liebst
welche welche die planen das eichenlaub
ja
welches holz war das noch mal muss ich
noch jemals ist hab ich hier aber ich
brauche ich hatte gerade sortiert dass
es geht einfach über das set oben rechts
machst du das mal selber bei der kiste
links daneben zeigt einfach dass z oo
ban rechts es automatisch zu den positiv
ist sagte lederer linke kiste linke
kiste daraus linke kirsten simon hatte
lobte scolari hat das holz hast du
wieder selber aufgenommen seien ins haus
ja ich weiß nicht wir brauchen eine
einteilung oder da brauchen wir das
nicht
würde doch klar ich kann mir so richtig
wollte gerade ein sprecher
so wie wir dürfen jetzt ruhig sein denn
wir sind am baum konstellation können an
den soll noch ein bisschen zu pflanzen
runtergehen lassen so lian brauchen wir
noch aussuchen mit der schere
abschneiden
ja genau jetzt wirklich als folgenlos
ihre spende ich bin kurzen spinnen
schlangen diadora die waffen dach mit
fackeln sitzen eltern total vergessen
aber nein egal ich gehe schon hoch ok
dabei habe ich erst mal richtig viele
ist es schon das wird was geht was es
ist nicht so einfach 5 millionen aus es
ist ein richtiges vernünftiges dach da
oben draufpacken kann ich so der kader
komplett zu treffen und zu hass oder wir
machen da oben sondern raum nicht raum
wir machen uns allerdings auf seiner
dachterrasse etwas auftrieb erhält
jemand alter simon du kannst du nicht
einfach bei nacht raus lauf und dann und
dann rückwärts gmbh
wir zeigen wie cool aus
ich hab' ich hab' ich hab' ich hab's
teil und das geld
ich habe damals als spieler da mal ganz
optimal druckplatte macht sie machen
eine druckplatte 333
mit dem lande oder 222 was okay jetzt
trotzdem schlagen ich glaube ich mache
den bogen und packte stärker eins drauf
oder so weil wir brauchen nicht den
bogen wenn ihr die ganzen körper sind
oder wir müssen echt seine farben machen
ich glaube wir machen in dem jetzt mal
die farben damit erstmal was mit viel
spaß gemacht
also diese mails raider und so was alles
das heißt ich würde sagen wir können
jetzt erst mal wieder um die
wesentlichen dinge farm und sowas ist ja
keinen 50 folgen let's play wir sind
doch schon über 50 folgen nicht wirklich
40 bisschen werden ja aber wir werden
uns schon noch mit viel witz
beschäftigen als ganz ganz ruhig und
wenn ihr das nicht gut findet dann
müssen gucken genau halt einfach
abschalten und positiv bewerten weil
dann gucken wir mal die kulisse hier ist
es dass die das ist dass die serie für
die coole kids sorgt wir sind als team
dabei sieben minuten bei der bei der
fünften folge die wir gern aufnehmen das
heißt wenn ihr immer noch dran seid
könnt ihr einfach mal viel zu bieten die
kommentare schreiben
natürlich vorne links was doch klar
leider können mops darauf dreht und
einkommen nein wie dumm doch natürlich
deswegen darf man das sony und du kannst
auch einfach wenn du willst dass treten
an durchlaufen dann geht es auch relativ
egal
ok na gut das sieht schon schon schön
aus hier ein bisschen mit pflanzen und
zu recht so ach ja ich wollte da oben
noch ein bisschen was dran bauen
trautes heim glück allein hat monster
wird
roter schaufel studie neues offen für
altem endlich geht online zu endlich
dass ich noch kann ja ich höre dich noch
immer um gott keine blöcke ersetzen wer
verliert man so geht das nicht
den eigentlichen ich mache zu sagen wer
jetzt vorschnell knochenmark und farben
farben
du musst einfach machen du kannst nicht
verhungern hast du brot dass du jetzt
ist drin
das wird sich aber nicht beim spinnen
auge reicht es ist eine gute idee hier
noch steine hinzusetzen
was wie findest du sie das aus hatte
aber ich finde es absurd
unser haus ist wie auf einer erhöhung
sind ja ein bisschen komisch es besser
wenn das den stein machen kommen wir
jetzt so ein bisschen blätter dran
gepackt wie finster dass er wie findest
du das hier mache das hier ist unser
haus ist er begeistert dass es unten
noch so eine geschichte ist star war
vorher werde so ein stein oder was
anderes
ja kann man so lassen sowie stein- oder
mit anderen stellen oder sony passt
passt ja dann mache ich einmal rundherum
mit diesen stein gut die hälfte beim ab
und ich muss meinen schafen in die
lehrpläne mit einer neuen masche einfach
durch die andere seite genau an meinem
engen meine rechte hand es eingeschlafen
ich muss mal ganz kurz stehen bleiben
weil ich kann gar nicht als wsa ada ist
die steuern will ich alle meine linke
hand ist ein geschlossenes erfolg alt
die in wien